[Music]
so uh before we go I want to send you
off with a little piece of information
that will change your life forever in a
segment we call blow your
mind
whoa so this is what's blowing my mind
lately lately uh we are uh we're on a
planet a a planet are you listening
we're on a planet right now right now
flying through nothing a planet that's
attached to nothing when's the last time
you thought about that never no one
worries about it cuz in kindergarten
they're like don't worry gravity and
you're like got it never going to think
about that again you're on a planet
you're flying when
always you're always flying you've never
not been flying people say they're
afraid of flying when you're flying in
an airplane you're taking off of
something that's also flying double
flying I know that seemed pretty common
to you but there's one stone person at
home that's
[Applause]
like that's our show
[Music]
everybody